well thanks everyone for being here
this is going to be fun amazing
interesting awesome thanks thanks pete
thanks for the roast
the least i could do
um so i want to let you introduce
yourselves and we can just start with
george and go down the line and tell us
sort of your focus area and how you got
into venture
yeah i guess i'll start uh george
matthew with inside partners been in
venture capital i guess officially for
only about 14 months or so um was mostly
a founder entrepreneur like most
everyone on this audience here mostly
working on data analytics ml ai
companies
i got to
the venture world predominantly by just
building companies so i was
i was the president of alteryx um it was
kind of building alteryx from its sort
of get-go into
a public company readiness um outfit
that you know we took public in 2017 uh
became ceo caspari was doing a lot of
image video analytics on two petabytes
of image video data and running machine
learning models against it and then
my current boss jeff horing the founder
of insight
had a idea that we should be going a
little bit earlier into series a series
b companies and
that's what i did to go join insight did
26 deals in the last
14 months
mostly focused on great companies in the
space half of which i think i invested
in
awesome well i first want to
congratulate pete uh i think when i
first met pete maybe four or five years
ago five years ago at this point this
community was was much much smaller and
this is uh
i'm incredibly impressed by just how
robust this has been so congratulations
my name is joanne i'm a general partner
here at foundation
i we mostly do very early stage
investing so starting at
inception sometimes the companies don't
even exist
and we are primarily focused on
helping companies go for
from zero to one um so everything a
foundation has been built around this
from recruiting to customer networks to
angel networks etc um firms been around
for 26 years uh we have about 400
portfolio companies 31 ipos
we invest in enterprise fintech and web
3.
um
in terms of my journey to venture i've
been
inventor for about a decade at this
point i did a short stint at cisco i
worked on my own startup i studied
engineering computer science
and then i kind of accidentally started
angel investing before meeting
initially the folks at formation 8 and
then
more recently
about eight years ago the folks at
foundation
very excited about everything that's
been happening in ai machine learning
data
infrastructure web3
and excited to chat more about that with
you today
uh bogomill bulkanski i'm a partner at
sequoia been at the firm for a couple of
years now so relative newcomer to the
field
before that i actually had a real job
like many of you i was making software
and putting in the hands of customers
my true wheelhouse is product management
and product marketing
spent
eight years at vmware leading the
product management product marketing
team for the core
hypervisor platform
then went to a startup spent some time
at google cloud
how did i find myself in venture after
my stint at google cloud i took a nice
long sabbatical and i was about to start
a company
when sequoia came calling and
here i am
an investor
given my background from vmware google
cloud i mostly focus on geeky stuff
developer tools devops
data infrastructure security
so really glad to be here
many friends already
and looking forward to meeting more of
you
amazing and it's great to have operators
and technical folks um with with
varying business and technical
backgrounds on stage so
um thanks for sharing so i wanted to
kind of ask about the state of the union
um
overall um
like what are the patterns that you're
seeing now in data infrastructure
machine learning etc
um that you might not have expected
to have seen just a few years ago like
where where are we seeing increased
adoption
sort of what are the what are the big
memes the the big themes that you're
seeing um across the space these days
so good i guess i'll start
i i really focused on on two big themes
um no surprise in this room
one was
everything related to the unbundling of
everything
associated with etl to elt
and the modern data stack that is
arising around that that movement and a
lot of it was just kind of centered
around cloud native data warehouses and
cloud native data lakes or delta lakes
and
cloud
lake houses or whatever we're calling
them these days but
but the fact that like you can now do
transformation in database and you can
actually have
a separation of the logic that was
effectively transformation that was
previously in etl is a profound change
it actually drives a fair number of
opportunities to create a system of
record in in cloud-native data
warehouses and so a lot of my investment
thesis was around the tooling associated
with that the second was ml ops so
everything related to
when you look at this sort of
opportunity that you see in this market
particularly around just making it more
straightforward to get things into
production because it is really hard to
get models into production uh went all
the way from you know first-party
third-party data blending with explorium
lead weights and biases and everything
related to experiment tracking type
parameter tuning
rosco was effectively building a feature
store natively on top of snowflake as
well as fiddler of course doing model
monitoring model production so that
entire tool chain uh was quite important
to me and then you know there were some
interesting opportunities to like
re-bundle things together uh y42 was one
of my favorite rebundling plays
which went after just a very focused
uh targeted play for for dtc ecommerce
but just a bundle stack just just making
it easier for for everyone to like just
get product out the door particularly
from a data standpoint so yeah it's uh
it's a pretty pretty broad mandate but i
think anything that has life and next
generation data i love
and it didn't take long only five
minutes in and we already had our first
rebundle unbundle
bundle reference
thank you for that
i knew it wouldn't take long there's
people with bingo cards out there so i
hope you scored some points i should
have taken out three or four points
right there
are we also playing a game where we have
to insert a weird word in the middle of
our talk and we get points for it
from my perspective
maybe the most interesting trend is that
or the most interesting new pattern is
that
there are multiple different patterns
that happily co-exist in the data
infrastructure
so on one hand yes of course you know
the modern data stack is a revolution
that's gathering speed and and we all
know about it
but
at the same time as the modern data
stack is taking shape in many
organizations you do have um
end-to-end all-in-one products like y42
and i often get asked like well what
which way should i go like you know do i
implement the modern data stack you know
should i go with something like an
end-to-end product and
and interestingly that it's it's not an
either or answer like so you have
the data science data engineering team
building the modern data stack
you have line of business people who
quite honestly like can't
just
take a ticket and wait um to be served
by the central data authority so at some
point they take
things in their own hands and implement
their own tools
and so when it comes to end-to-end tools
you see horizontal ones but you also see
vertical ones that specifically serve
the needs of like the marketing team or
the sales ops team etc
so it's a very interesting trend um
and speaking about the lake house yes
you know you have the data warehouses
you have a data lakes and again it's not
an either or in most companies beyond
certain scale you tend to
have both like coexist happily
and then to keep kind of adding on
different patterns now you have what
i'll call
a virtual data warehouse so you have all
of these query engines like starburst
that allow you not to etl the data like
it stays where it is and you know you
can query it real time you can serve it
real time in in applications etc and
rockset is another example of that and
so it's very interesting that like all
of these different trends and all these
different patterns like very happily
coexist
in the same customer serving different
needs of different personas different
business units etc
all good news because you know it's it's
not a competition among different
vendors there is uh there's plenty of
opportunity for
pretty much any pattern
um at a company at serving a customer
beyond certain certain scale
well i'm glad we're talking about this
already because um
this whole
bundling unbundling
best of breed point solutions versus
end-to-end platforms
um i'm curious joanna if you have
thoughts on that topic because i wonder
like how long we can continue to double
triple quadruple up on best of breed
tools in in that completely overlap or
apparently overlapping
individual like how many data quality
companies can this community support
yeah this is sort of what i'm getting at
well one of the things i wanted to touch
upon that was related to what bogamill's
talking about and and this is a little
bit more abstracted but answering your
question um is
we're super excited about
the importance of
data as as respect to the importance of
code from a decade ago or even five
years ago right that movement has been
shifting and data as an asset as
everybody here would agree is
becoming the most important asset in any
organization so i think in the beginning
uh data was used by some of the larger
players like you know facebook and
netflix to just understand their users a
little bit better right and then now
data
as an asset is um is is operationally
strategic
you know do are we are kpis are we are
we uh
is there anomalies uh in our data it's
also
go to market strategic meaning you know
what kind of users should we go and
target
and then it's also product strategic
meaning we're building data products
like uber as a data product which is a
data product
a lot of our
favorite companies are data data
products so
that means
you know every single function needs to
be able to
tap into this access this related to
what bogama was talking about which
means the opportunities
for both consolidation and point
solutions are specific to the to the use
cases so my guess is today uh this this
area has been very much invested in and
we're seeing lots of best of breed
tooling
my expectation is that
just like any other industry the best
will stay relevant and we'll see
consolidation more and more so
especially as the larger companies
understand you know their market cap has
been growing very very quickly in the
last last couple years and they
understand the strategic importance of
this
got it
so before we go like a little bit lower
level let's sort of stay broad um how do
you think about the size and the growth
potential of this market overall like
what sort of
mental model do you have that sort of
informs
how much time you spend in
looking at data tools or machine
learning stuff versus versus other
options in the enterprise
so i i think we're all underestimating
the size of the data market again right
i think if we look at what the last
generation of data tools look like and
even the generation before that you know
these are you know sizably speaking some
of the biggest aspects of the software
market and were out of the oracles and
yeah saps oracles uh uh you know
business objects like those were um
big companies right and they got to
scale in a much smaller software space
right and now software is somewhere in
the neighborhood of like 20 x bigger
right 20 to 30 x bigger than it was and
data is probably you know a substantial
portion of that space
so i you know how many data quality
companies can we have a ton of data
companies right it actually turns out
like
there's a lot of room to play big and
and and build big companies i think i
think what you have to sit back and and
not worry about is is like okay how much
is this going to consolidate in the
future it's like go figure out a persona
go figure out a market go figure out a
customer go serve them well build a 100
million dollar business
it's all possible for everyone in this
room
[Applause]
i think we see we see this the
several of you have mentioned the the
focus because
um you know we might see data tool for x
and um data tool for y
and sometimes they might seem to overlap
but in reality they they target
completely different users of the stack
um and so i think we see this with
certain kinds of
machine learning and data science
infrastructure where
a company like orchest
might be giving data scientists
infrastructure to spin up that obviate
the need of the data engineering team to
exist in a particular kind of company
so even though you might call that their
their their product data infrastructure
it's infrastructure for data scientists
and not necessarily for data engineers
so we i do see that in this community
where
folks have to be it's not just about the
product they're building it's about the
combination of the product they're
building and who it's specifically
targeted at because it can look like a
completely different company down the
road if they're laser focused on on who
their user persona or their
ideal customer profile is
i mean as a former product manager and
still product manager at heart this
really resonates for me because the
advice that i always give companies is
you know your product
cannot be uh
all things to all people
um it cannot be good for everybody but
it better be amazing for somebody
and you know better have this clarity of
thought from the very beginning who is
that somebody that your product would be
like truly amazing for
yeah i think bugamon's um got a great
point there right so so when i
when i was president of alteryx there
was um the moment that i know i won
wasn't like you know when baltic said
100 million in revenue and we took it
public the moment i know i i won was
when were about 15 million
and people who were data analysts would
come up to me
and early days in our conference and and
literally say can i give you a hug i'm
like i don't know you why right i'm like
well i just want to let you know that
like i had a massive challenge with
getting 15 different sources of files
together and i couldn't get to my son's
baseball game on friday afternoon
and now i can and i just want to let you
know it like literally changes like the
way i get my work done like you build a
company like that
and you know there's no one that can
stop you and i think that's what you
have to keep thinking about when you're
particularly in this data space persona
based driven experiences that are
fundamentally life-changing for how
people work
one of the things that
sometimes we advise
our data companies is
let's take some of the lessons from
application companies or consumer
companies
in terms of the focus of the persona
right like i think right now we are
still underestimating the market size of
this whole ecosystem
and if we look at the software
engineering market
uh companies have a lot more clarity
today around who they're serving in the
software engineering space what are your
front-end engineer or your back-end
engineer are you a design-centric person
are you you know engineering for this
type of
company and i think that kind of clarity
we want to bring
um in the data space one because i think
the rules will actually expand and we'll
see a lot more
types of people who are
building and that clarity will come as
the ecosystem matures and second because
of everything that
you know bogomill and george and pete
has said um
you've got to win you have limited
resources
survival is what happens
what what the goal is in the beginning
and to have little resources and people
to survive someone has to get promoted
someone has to love you
and yeah as data gets closer sort of
moves up closer to the business user and
becomes
required
table stakes for
business teams marketing teams finance
teams etc
um do you start do you think we'll start
to see a greater democratization of
sort of those folks driving what becomes
the the next generation of data
infrastructure right i feel like we've
been kind of building databases and
feature stores and metric stores and etl
pipelines in this community for years
but i kind of feel like the business now
is starting to
um
like
they have more consciousness of the fact
that they sort of need to drive some of
these requirements for the type of data
they need when they need it i'm
wondering if you see like a greater
democratization of access for these
folks sort of being built on top of all
the systems that we've sort of been you
know myopically focused on over the
years
i can start first of all i we've been
investing in enabling everybody
in the organization to have this power
because
there's a shortage good for you guys
talent in the space and how do you bring
that automation augmentation to the rest
of the organization that's been a huge
huge trend um i think the second uh part
that's that's uh important in this is
that
um
to your point about democratization
there's um
there's you know for example operational
real-time data analytics has been a very
popular thing to do but who actually
cares about this right today
decision-making is in some ways more and
more decentralized but as we saw in you
know other uh other ecosystems there has
been a swing of technical buyers to
business buyers
back to technical buyers
now to a hybrid and i suspect the same
thing will happen uh in the in the data
space as this matures
peter question reminds me a little bit
of uh a marketing campaign that new
relig had maybe like four or five years
ago with these billboards plastered all
over san francisco and other cities if
we're all data geeks
um
to me the trend of like everybody
working with data is is not new
uh and of course it's gathering steam
and i think it it manifests itself on on
multiple levels
um business users kind of grasping for
more analytics more dashboards like
analyzing their business is only one
aspect
of everything becoming data driven but
if you take for example a modern
marketer and how they work
and what are the tools um that they use
every day
you know their marketing automation
system it may be something like iterable
or brace or marketo you know etc if you
look under the covers of every single
marketing automation system today it's a
big data infrastructure and data
wrangling product
um and marketers don't necessarily
experience it like that directly but you
know one of the most interesting things
that has happened in the world of
marketing in the last few years is
segment you know like a powerful data
pipeline to be able to collect all the
data from from from everywhere
um and then that feeds your marketing
automation system but under the covers
again it's all about slicing and dicing
data being able to create segments etc
and so
i would say
most
business line of business applications
that every functional leader that every
employee in like you know every function
today is using
increasingly under the covers is
basically huge data wrangling
operation and to me that is actually
almost like a more interesting aspect of
data enablement
of
everybody whose title is has nothing to
do with data than just the traditional
like analytical dashboards and slicing
and dicing you know uh analytics
yeah so we'll see um
we'll see how quickly the
sql becomes
required sort of language knowledge for
business users i think that's something
a lot of us in this community are always
kind of keeping one eye open for right
like to what extent can we insist that
people learn sql
even if they're a business analyst
so
so we'll we'll see with definitely a
vote of confidence there um
so i want to kind of like turn the turn
the conversation towards the founders or
the potential founders in the audience
because there's lots of people in data
council who have started and who will
start companies um
where's the biggest white space like if
the the ecosystem is so crowded and if
there's six different point solutions in
every category where should folks in
this community be looking for
opportunities
so i i'm a big proponent now of what's
happening around
unstructured
and particularly like unstructured
analysis when it comes to
unsupervised deep learning uh i've been
looking at a lot of uh work that's
particularly been happening on large
language models transformers
semantic search uh that could be kind of
layered on top and you're not now just
seeing that for kind of nlp use cases so
the the fact that like
the transformer-based approach is you
know transfer learning has kind of now
shifted over to computer vision use
cases and you're kind of seeing that now
in computer vision and other sort of
realms beyond just nlp um that's a big
area of interest for me and uh probably
going to talk to every anyone or anyone
who's interested in that space so come
by and chat if you have some work you're
doing there
[Music]
to me i see a couple of areas that are
very interesting to me
one is a byproduct of the fact that i
also spend a bunch of time in the areas
of observability and security
and when we talk about data we
traditionally think about
business data that gets generated by
business applications and venue etl like
you know the data you put in the data
warehouse you know etc
but let's not forget that in every
enterprise
there are other domains that generate
inordinate amount of data
i would argue that observability or like
system monitoring is all about data i
would argue that splunk is a data
company the elks tech is all about
um data
similar analogy i think applies to
security where every security tool
basically spits out like a whole bunch
of data that needs to be stored that
needs to be transformed etc
and so in the world of business data
we have like you know this wonderful
thing called the modern data stack and i
fully expect the equivalent of the
modern data stack over time to emerge
in the domains of observability and
and security and maybe it's not a
one-on-one translation so
i'm not suggesting people starting
creating pitches like you know we are
like the five tran for security or the
five trend for observability
um
but i do believe that um
we will see some of the disciplines that
have emerged from the modern data stack
be transplanted
onto these other domains that generate
inordinate amounts of data and i think
we've started kind of seeing the
glimmers the beginnings of these trends
for example there's a company called
monad that does
data pipelines for security
and it's very similar to what
segment did for customer data what
router stack that or does for customer
data
i was talking to um
thought from eurodb yesterday and you
know we're doing
something similar for the observability
stack and so
that entire area is very interesting to
me kind of modern data stack for other
very data
um heavy
domains
and then the second trend that is that i
think is is it's ripe for opportunity is
um
you know software was eating the world
like starting 20 years ago now data is
seeding the world and every company is a
data company and so if you believe in
all of that
i think that the world of data is still
at kind of the
artisanal stage of
how
you do things
and i do believe that over time a lot of
the best practices
that have been implemented in the world
of software development
will be implemented in the world of data
and data pipelines so call it git ops
for for data whatever you're going to
call it but
i do expect that we'll see
more discipline and rigor
in terms of how
anything data related is being created
version controlled can be audited over
time there's a discipline process how
some a data pipeline
can or cannot go into production so i
anticipate to see the emergence of
ci cd systems like for data
and so to me
that is also a very interesting area of
exploration
and somebody mentioned data
observability or like data quality
companies to me that is like one of the
manifestations of a trend right so
you know in the world of software system
we've had monitoring observability flow
for many many years and now the data has
become more crucial and more important
bum all of a sudden we have monitoring
for data and observability for data and
so again i expect many of the things
that we have in the software development
life cycle to start emerging for the
data processing life cycle if i can call
it that
on our end
we're excited about all the things that
has been mentioned
observability
as well as computer vision
and security cyber security all these
things but i'll touch upon something
else that hasn't been mentioned which is
the convergence of
web 3 and web 2.
um so we started investing in web 3 in
2014 if you can't believe that was not
very fruitful at the time
and i remember
in even in 2017-2018
we would see
pitch decks of
you know founders that
were
much different kind of than the founders
that you were seeing in the enterprise
space because maybe they didn't have the
backgrounds or capabilities but very few
people who had
kind of the credibility to go and start
a company
today that has
completely changed
completely changed uh we were at
uh you know one of the crypto
conferences recently and i would say
you know it is just as robust and high
quality as
you know data council that the
individuals who attended which means if
everybody believes in this concept it
will eventually become true right even
if even if you're a pessimist
and so i think this is uh there's a lot
of opportunities in that space
security
observability developer tooling except
this is
probably 20 years less mature than what
we're seeing today and i think there's a
lot of opportunities there to build
yeah i completely agree i'm also very
interested in
blockchain infrastructure
because there's parallels and and
analogs to what we see in the data
infrastructure world
and like you said the developer tooling
that needs to pop up around web3
there's a lot of lessons that this
community can share
um with web3 founders because there's a
whole infrastructure layer that needs to
be built and is being built and
sometimes it's being built accidentally
in web 3 but it needs to be built much
more intentionally by um some of the
folks who are in this room
um so i wanted our credit we went for a
full half an hour before mentioning
webfree
sorry sorry i couldn't resist
so um i do want to leave some time for
questions
from the audience so if you have a
question please be ready um
i do want to like touch on one topic
though quickly if if we can open a new
topic quickly and that would be open
source
um
are you still excited and
interested in open source gtm models and
or do you think we're seeing some break
in
this previously perceived sort of
straight line from open source adoption
to
having building a successful commercial
product i feel like we're seeing some
sort of break in that where it's it's
not as obvious as founders used to think
it was to be able to flip over your open
source user base into a commercial
product um do you perceive that to be
true and are you excited about open
source gtm in general
it has never been straightforward like
to flip from
an open source product to a commercial
product that has always been
a very tough balance to navigate and you
know you have the cautionary tale of
terraform for example you know beloved
products ubiquitously used if you look
at the p l of cashew core very little of
their revenue actually comes from
terraform and you know credit to them
they created like other hit products
that were able to monetize
um
i think open source continues to be like
very interesting distribution mechanism
um
in my mind though it only helps
if your product is targeted very
technical people and if your product has
a value proposition for a single user
and
if those two criteria are met then yes
then open source will help you because
you'll have an engineer or data
scientist you know etc pull something
you know off the web tinker with it like
oh they go
and obviously there are so many examples
of powerful companies
uh huge companies that have been built
on top of open source
um but sometimes
i see companies not being very
thoughtful about
um
kind of these aspects of what are the
criteria for open source to actually
help you and again unless you have a
value prop for a single user
unless you're targeting very technical
person then i don't know if open source
does anything for you
that's a good question i think yes and
it depends to your quest to your
question um i was having this
conversation with uh neha who's one of
the co-founders of confluence just a
couple weeks ago like what has what has
changed in this ecosystem
um for a startup
to be successful i think if you take uh
a step back
ubiquity has been the goal for open
source company in the past ubiquity and
then commercialization or monetization
and today i think that has changed
because there's so many attempts at
growing both the community as well as
um as well as monetization and and
extracting value much sooner without
ubiquity i think there are some
advantages to this model by the way you
could use the the community and iterate
much faster right you can test out a
bunch more things uh and shorten this
the cycle i do think the pitfall of open
source companies today is that that
thoughtfulness is not there like why is
this supposed to be open source why
should you monetize why does this user
care
the same things that apply to non-open
source companies still apply here
there's not a lower bar right and i
think that's like some of the issues
that we're seeing today which is the
lack of thoughtfulness around uh using
this uh ecosystem
the the line isn't a straight line at
all as as you called out people you kind
of look at you know even the most
successful
data
focused open source companies i'll just
i'll just spend a second there
when you see
you know good example of uh of recent
open source work um that found you know
some scale and now growing uh like a
a monstrous company at this point is uh
is airflow right you look at what
happened with airflow over the last
several years
um there were some real challenges right
uh to the airflow community what airflow
was kind of delivering into the market
and then you know over over the years
where you know max and everyone else
that was associated with airflow in the
beginning got together with the
astronomer team and
came back and and pushed airflow 2.0
like it was just a whole different
company right it was a whole different
experience for for the airflow community
and that just created rocket ship right
there you know the flip side of this you
have something like cassandra right
where every step of the way you know
data stacks um as a commercial offering
of cassandra was in open warfare with
the open source community around it like
literally you had moments where you know
the data sacks team and i've talked to
billy about this um over the years
where they would release features and
those features would just like literally
just show up as as open source
capability inside of core cassandra so i
i think i think you have to just kind of
figure out the right way to
not only kind of build a community and
figure out the commercialization
strategy but but also like really
understand what's what's important for
that community and serve the community
well enough that you can kind of
differentiate and build and have the
privilege to build a um a
commercialization play on top of the the
open source work and so so the ones who
do that all like the two things that we
just mentioned plus plus kind of
figuring out the right way to navigate
the community in a way that you know
both commercial and open source
interests matter
those can be big companies right and you
have
a great example in databricks right i
mean so i was just catching up with ali
last week it's a billion dollar business
growing 80 percent year over year right
the underpinnings is still spark right
and there's obviously other things that
they've produced as far as commercial
products go but the under spent
underpinning is still you know an open
source project so so there there's
there's good bad and ugly uh when when
it comes to building with with an open
source mindset
great
thank you
uh let's take a question
who's ready
i think there's a microphone back there
somewhere
anyone
no one has a question for the sharks
there's a question over there
all right we got we have a taker
the mic is coming
hi
um i want to ask the opposite of the
white question so
what are the products we're building or
problems we're solving um that don't
actually have business value like where
do you think we're wasting our time
i'm looking for a spicy take
what not to build
pete do you want to take that
one what not to build
well i don't think this is too generic
but but don't build something
if you don't have the user in mind right
like sometimes founders like
we are our own customer and
i think this is kind of a oic insight
right it's solve the problem that's
that's sort of most important to you
solve your own problem first and sort of
be your own customer first
when i was an engineer starting
companies
i built because i thought it was
cool
right i
i thought the world needed api security
in 2008.
so i built that thing well the world did
not care about api security in 2008.
um so i guess for me you know the the
inverse of that this is not a category
maybe which you're hoping for but it's
just make sure that you know who you're
building for and that they care about it
first everything else is worth worthless
let me maybe
try to answer the question in a
slightly different way which is
having a great product is unnecessary
but by no means a sufficient condition
for success and as a young company
where
you tend to trip over it's not in your
ability to deliver a product that would
delight some user
it's in your ability like to gain
distribution
and i think you need to be very
thoughtful about
how
fragmented how occupied how noisy is the
space that you're going after and ask
yourself the question of
hey
even if i have a great product would it
matter
if there are
20 other companies like you know vying
for attention and you may be solving a
very legitimate business need like you
may truly
be the best product but
the question becomes how are we going to
rise above the noise how are we going to
let these prospects how are we going to
get their attention how are we going to
let them know that hey you truly have
like the solution like to their problem
and
unless you have a good answer to that
question like how are you going to stand
out
like how are you going to get some
distribution advantage
um i'm not saying that you're wasting
your time
but i think
because this is not the the
intuition of a technical founder
typically and most of you are technical
founders like you're obsessed about the
product you obsess about
you know serving a customer you don't
necessarily wake up every morning and
think about marketing and distribution
and stuff like that and and
and i think
that's
that's where
you need to focus a lot to figure out
are you wasting your time or not
i i have a finally an example
of we this is not in the data space but
i'll just give a generic
no names example we invest in this
company
many many years back that
was a valley on demand service
right like who doesn't want that you're
driving in san francisco you're driving
downtown austin
you could just leave your car someone
comes and parks your car like that
sounds fantastic especially to the vcs
fantastic product
[Laughter]
the company didn't survive
it was economically
not viable
maybe not forever on viable but at the
time unviable because it was so
expensive for someone to come and you
know there were errors maybe they can't
find your car maybe they don't have to
start it because you're driving a manual
and all sorts of problems arose and it
was economically viable
so i take that kind of example to this
world
you know one thing to think about is
you know you have a product you have
happy customers
if your customer is willing to pay you
five bucks for your product and it takes
you 12 months to sell this product
it's probably an economically unviable
business all the time
you could do that for some time but you
know hopefully after some time you're
able to
uh
strike a balance between the cost
and and what you're getting
if we're to uh tell more cautionary
tales um
sometimes there is something like um the
world is not ready for your idea and
again you might be so market timing is
so so important
again many of your visionaries like the
reason you start companies is that you
can see
around the corner you can see further
along and and sometimes your customers
are or potential customers maybe like
years behind you and it's
very ironic how sometimes you know one
idea flops and then like a decade later
that's a very same idea like you know
succeeds
you know that's another thing that i'll
obsess as a founder like is the market
ready for for my idea and sometime
seemingly my new changes in execution
beat on the product side or go to market
side make all the difference
you know tell us from let's say sequoia
history is a close investor in a web van
in the early 2000s and we know how that
ended and then a decade later sequoia is
an investor in instacart and you know
that worked
and the differences are not that subtle
like you know one you built these you
know huge warehouses and that was hugely
capital intensive you know tetra
the other one didn't do that but again
these are like interesting examples of
how
like the market may not be ready for you
and likes and differences in execution
make all the difference
well um excellent thank you for that
question that was thought-provoking i
can tell the the panel is remusing
um so thank you for for joining us it's
been a really great chat um we're gonna
move on with the schedule and and let
folks get to the track rooms but but
thanks for being here i really
appreciate it thank you so much
[Applause]